bonsoir il y a un an après les attentats
que nous commémorons cette semaine vous
avez publié cette photo sur facebook
avec un message à 20 ans j'étais jeune
et salafiste à 39 ans je suis une femme
musulmane libre
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
ça aurait été dommage de se lever d'une
jolie femme je suis d'accord
[Musique]
alors depuis cette photo il y a eu une
pluie de louange et aussi des torrents
de haine aujourd'hui vous publiez chez
Flammarion j'ai choisi d'être libre et
vous en parlez dans Salut les Terriens
merci à alors vous êtes né à Rouen le 4
décembre 1976 père d'origine algérienne
et il travaille dans une usine de
produits chimiques votre mère d'origine
tunisienne et femme au foyer côté
religion à la maison on pratique pas et
un jour donc votre cousine
Latifa meurt électrocuté sa mort vous
semble inadmissible et ça vous rapproche
de la religion vous cherchez une réponse
à ce drame
oui à ce moment là ça a été dans ma vie
la première fois où je suis confrontée à
la mort d'un être qui m'était très cher
à la maison votre mère vous tape dessus
ce qui fait que vous vous repliez sur
vous-même vous devenez solitaire
jusqu'au jour vous rencontrez Sébastien
alors ce Sébastien en fait les Français
il s'est converti à l'islam il vous
explique les hadits et vous vous êtes
assez scolaire vous recopiez tout ce qui
vous dit sur un cahier quoi à 21 ans
vous êtes en licence de psycho et vous
commencez à faire des rêves étranges
vous vous voyez voilé tournant et
psalmodiant autour de la Kaaba à la
Mecque je sortais de l'adolescence et
donc j'avais une quête de pureté parce
que ma mère était persuadée que je
n'étais pas une fille sérieuse que
j'allais sortir avec des garçons
finalement j'ai j'ai décidé de d'aller
vers l'Islam et de et de porter le voile
c'est plus une dimension militante que
spirituelle en fait au départ oui je me
souviens à l'époque j'étais rebelle et
puis aussi j'avais une idée de la
relation aux hommes qui étaient
complètement faussée en fait je voyais
tous les hommes comme des pervers des
prédateurs et donc il fallait me
protéger de ça et pour ça le voile était
vraiment le bon moyen et puis quand vous
entrez dans l'amphithéâtre à la fac le
fait d'être voilé vous sentez supérieur
non seulement supérieur ou catholique
qui sont là mais aussi aux musulmans oui
il y avait une démarche un peu
narcissique c'est-à-dire que je me
sentais un peu plus supérieur aux autres
et je voulais aussi m'appartenir à une
communauté être reconnue dans la rue en
tant que musulmane et puis dans la cité
aussi vous êtes respecté quoi oui c'est
vrai qu'à l'époque les garçons du
quartier quand ils me regardaient ils me
disaient Salem à l'école et il baissait
le regard et je me sentais très fier à
ce moment-là c'est là donc on était au
printemps 1998 vous avez 22 ans que
votre vie va basculer vous vous rendez
chez une fille dénommée asnia qui a 24
ans qui porte le ni cab c'est à dire
qu'il y a juste les yeux qui sont
visibles elle essaffistes
et elle nous explique tu sais la chanson
hôtel California des Eagles c'est une
chanson sataniste ce soir là j'ai
découvert que la société c'était le
diable le diable était partout et il
voulait nous mener à notre perte voilà
et donc elle vous explique qu'il faut
arrêter de traîner à la fac qu'il faut
vous marier et vous occuper de votre
mari et de vos enfants et que c'est la
seule chose à faire le lendemain vous
recevez un appel d'un certain Bachir
quand vous comprenez Castilla jouait
l'entremetteuse évidemment elle vous
appelle pas par hasard vous acceptez de
le rencontrer vous avez pas vraiment
d'attirance pour lui ah non pas du tout
moi je m'attendais absolument pas à cet
appel téléphonique parce que j'avais
expliqué à Signac je ne voulais pas me
marier que je tenais à continuer mes
études tout en gardant le voile mais
sans me demander l'autorisation et c'est
permis de donner mon numéro de téléphone
donc
voilà et donc il m'a appelé aussitôt
pour me proposer une rencontre en vue
d'un éventuel mariage religieux commence
par vous expliquer qu'une femme ne doit
pas travailler qu'une femme ne doit pas
avoir son permis de conduire et surtout
il finit par vous convaincre de
l'épouser quand même j'ai vraiment pensé
que cette rencontre c'était simplement
une rencontre
juste pour faire connaissance et puis
pourquoi pas quelques années après
peut-être envisager un mariage religieux
mais ça pas du tout été le cas pas du
tout partez en Tunisie pour vous marier
et au retour du mariage vous faites une
escale à Paris pour acheter des voiles
des gilbabs des nikab et à côté il y a
un magasin qui vend des livres où on
prône la polygamie et la lapidation de
la femme adultère oui tout à fait en
fait nous sommes allés dans un quartier
à Paris donc qui s'appelle couronne ou
là-bas il y avait énormément de
librairies salafiste et donc c'est là
qu'on a acheté beaucoup de gilbab des
voiles et puis aussi des livres de
savant saoudiens donc salafiste on est
dans le 20e arrondissement alors votre
mari donc porte la barbe la djellaba la
calotte il est assez séduite par son
look vous dites finalement mon mec il
ressemble au Prophète quoi exactement
vous allez la passer quelques jours chez
sa mère à Roanne avant qu'il reprenne le
travail et là vous découvrez que ce
Bachir ne travaille pas oui en fait je
découvre qu'il m'a menti sur toute la
ligne comme la relation est un petit peu
compliquée avec ses parents finissez par
dégoter un petit appartement où vous
allez habiter quand vous êtes enceinte
il refuse qu'un médecin homme vous
examine oui tout à fait ça c'était
primordial donc on a été à une clinique
privée pour être sûr de trouver une
femme gynécologue refuse que vous
portiez à la maison des jupes à
mi-mollet oui en fait plus le temps
passé plus il devenait exigeant sur ma
tenue vestimentaire et en fait il m'a il
m'a il fini par jeter
à la poubelle vos livres à la poubelle
enfin ça devient de plus en plus dur il
vous interdit d'aller à la fac vous
restez à la maison et là il vous apprend
le Coran et là vous découvrez des trucs
absolument incroyables par exemple si
une femme pubère passe devant un croyant
qui fait sa prière le croyant doit
recommencer exactement comme s'il y
avait un chien noir ou un âne qui
passait c'est que la femme donc émise au
niveau du chien et de l'âne elle est
considérée comme un pur donc étantatrice
alors il vous interdit même d'aller
prier à la mosquée exactement quand il
invite des amis à dîner vous devez
rester à la cuisine et vous passez les
plats sur un plateau mais il faut pas
qu'on vous voit non surtout pas en fait
je frappais à la porte pour lui faire
comprendre que les plats étaient prêts
les uns après les autres quand votre
enfant né il vous interdit de prendre
des photos de lui chez les salafistes
les photos les poupées sont interdites
parce que c'est il considère qu'on imite
la création de Dieu et cela est un grave
péché alors là vous vivez de du RMI et
des allocations familiales donc ça veut
dire que la France subventionne ces
pires ennemis en fait exactement le jour
où vous plaignez de cela vous prenez un
coup de poing dans le ventre tout à fait
c'est le premier ça a été le premier de
nombreuses autres couples que j'ai reçu
étant enceinte il n'hésite pas à vous
frapper oui et plus particulièrement
confiance
les Français il était leur coutume il
détestent leur fête et vous finissez par
croire que si ce Bachir ne trouve pas de
boulot c'est parce que les Français sont
mauvais parce que les Français ne
veulent pas de lui les Français ne nous
aiment pas un jour il croit que vous
parlez à un homme au téléphone et là il
vous répudie alors ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'on peut répudier les gens ça
c'est pas compliqué c'est religieusement
légal il vous aurait pu dire mais il
peut revenir sa décision tiens si vous
refaites l'amour avec lui vous êtes de
nouveau marié exactement on a trois
chances voilà
de revenir ensemble donc dans les trois
mois il faut avoir une relation sexuelle
avec son époux pour que les poumons
reprennent voilà bon alors évidemment ça
amène entre salafiste à des échanges de
femmes malheureusement c'est c'est le
cas les femmes sont considérées comme
des objets qu'on peut s'échanger qu'on
peut épouser et répudier du jour au
lendemain vous vous retrouvez chez vous
avec trois enfants sans argent sans
chéquier sans carte de crédit vous êtes
obligé d'aller bouffer au resto du coeur
c'est la seule solution qui vous reste
enda alors la plupart des femmes ça
l'affichent qui ne peuvent pas
travailler à cause du look quand elles
sont répudiées elles cherchent à se
remarier parce que si elles vivent sans
travailler on dit c'est des [ __ ] donc
elle cherche un mari donc elle passe des
petites annonces sur des sites qui sont
dédiés à ça et comme elles ont été
répudiées qu'elles n'ont pas de blé
finalement elles acceptent à peu près
n'importe quel mari qui va les traiter
comme de la merde en fait le mariage
c'est le fondement
de la doctrine salafiste c'est-à-dire
que dès qu'on est une femme se convertit
entre guillemets au salafisme et bien on
lui parle la première chose qu'on lui
propose c'est le mariage il ne faut
surtout pas qu'elle reste seule et il
nous faut surtout pas qu'elle soit
autonome et indépendante il faut qu'elle
soit sous l'emprise sous la coupe d'un
homme alors à un moment vous avez envie
que votre mari revienne quand même parce
que il y a pas trop d'autres solutions
vous simulez un suicide il revient et un
jour où vous revenez du marché avec un
petit ensemble rose et un foulard il
vous étrangle avec le foulard oui je
m'en souviens comme si c'était hier ça a
été très dur
un matin à 5h avec vos enfants sous le
bras vous prenez un taxi jusqu'à Rouen
700 bornes le matin où il devait partir
faire des papiers pour qu'on puisse
s'installer en Arabie Saoudite donc il
s'est rendu au consulat d'Arabie
Saoudite et là je décide de m'enfuir
jusqu'à Rouen à Rouen vous êtes convoqué
au commissariat et quand vous arrivez
vous apprenez quand même que vous étiez
surveillé tous les deux
il était fichée
dans son entourage des individus
dangereux alors là évidemment vous êtes
tellement influencé par cette doctrine
salafiste c'est que vous retirez votre
voile et quand vous allez danser dans un
bar par exemple ça y est le diable va me
tomber dessus quoi ça c'était longtemps
après mon divorce en fait quand je me
suis entre guillemets inséré dans la
société j'ai commencé à trouver du
boulot et puis des filles qui
travaillent avec moi m'avait proposé
d'aller boire un verre dans un bar c'est
vrai que j'étais persuadée que le diable
était en train de prendre possession de
mon esprit pas du tout c'est le groove
le 23 novembre 2015 vous publiez cette
photo sur facebook
en quelques jours il y a 80 000 like et
puis il y a aussi des insultes ça a été
très vite j'ai posté la photo sans
vraiment réfléchir moi c'était ma façon
à moi de d'exprimer mon ressenti suite
aux attentats du 13 novembre en 2015 et
à ce moment là il y a beaucoup de gens
qui ont partagé cette photo qui se sont
exprimées et qui avait besoin de de
libérer leur souffrance aussi
rayée vos pneus sont crevés ils
appellent téléphoniques on vous dit
Henda on sait où tu habites mais vous
tenez bon désormais vous savez que le
salafisme et l'antichambre du terrorisme
oui et que le seul avis est insoluble
dans la démocratie tout à fait
extraordinaire c'est que ceux qui vous
ont aidé c'est des démocrates des
chrétiens des juifs des athées des
homosexuels vous dites la générosité n'a
pas de religion
j'ai réalisé que je m'étais trompé sur
toute la ligne et qu'en fait le
salafisme m'avait
poussé à être tout ce que je ne voulais
pas être intolérante raciste haineuse
j'avais quitté
à aimer les hommes les êtres humains
quel que soit leur couleur de peau leur
religion je suis quelqu'un d'autre bravo
et merci pour tout petit
merci pour elle
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de Inna
larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu